and as many people are returning from
their holiday gatherings they want to
make sure they are covered free the
testing sites at unlv now back open
after a week they were closed for the
holiday that's where we find victoria
saha live with a look at how many people
are actually waiting and how long
they're waiting for a test victoria
this drive-through testing and vaccine
site opens in about 25 minutes these
cars were here first but take a look
behind me this is the line of cars just
waiting to get tested many of the
drivers i spoke with say they've been
waiting for more than two hours
the testing site closed from the 19th of
december and just reopened last night
where they tested more than 300 people
compare that to two weeks ago on sunday
the 12th they had less than 200 people
show up this location offers
drive-through testing as well as
vaccinations without an appointment our
team took precautions and spoke to those
waiting raita ellis was the first person
in line she got here around 3 p.m she
had coveted but needs a negative test to
return to work i'm glad i was first in
line everybody i pretty much came in
contact with at my office we all have it
this is not the only location for
testing nevada health response has
posted clinics labs and pharmacies
offering testing as well as where to
order the popular at-home kits
this site opens from sunday to thursday
5 30 to 10 30 and parents i do want to
tell you this site does not have
pediatric vaccines available
reporting from unlv tonight victoria
saha live local now